hey guys Chris waters here with a  gamespot news update controversial early  access game earth year 2066 has been  pulled off of steam valve is offering a  refund to any of you poor saps who  bought the thing earth year 2066  originally launched in april for twenty  dollars and it has been lambasted as a  barely functional disaster ouch early  access titles are expected to be works  in progress but valve says earth year  2066 cross the line valve statement says  on Steam developers make their own  decisions about promotion features  pricing and publication however steam  does require honesty from the developers  in the marketing of their games the  developer of the game has reportedly  censored complaints in the forums gotten  friends to post positive comments and  even wiped the entire forum so it looks  like it's curtains for Earth year 2060  six at least for now and if you're still  curious as to why just take a look at  this  you